well in terms of the periodic table if
this place didn't exist and people
didn't come here to work whole areas of
parody tape wouldn't wouldn't be there
now and it wouldn't be the periodic
table that we know today
so I'm let's go to the three and we're
about to get in the car together the
airport
it's nice sunny weather in Stockholm I
don't know what to think about this I'm
getting the feeling that I can't might
be covered in snow it may take a while
to to find a car
he left then take the exit left
take the exit left so we have reached
our destination
hi do you speak English yes yes continue
this road uh-huh
it's not much to see I'm sorry oh well
you know I think it's softer number
okay thank you very much thank you so
somewhere near number 65 and then you
basically take groove again no sorry
it's called feldspar swaggin thank you
very much close now and all the locals
know of it so it must be big it must be
famous
ah ah it's be groover so okay so it's
the birthplace of four elements of the
periodic table it reham ytterbium erbium
and terbium it to be mine historic
chemical landmark in my best Swedish so
here we see it trium ytterbium terbium
erbium all found for the first time for
minerals from gadelle in height in this
quarry and we were told by a nice
gentleman down the road that we can
follow the path up through the woods and
hopefully be able to see the mine so
let's go and see if we can find it
don't fall over
so we've reached the top where are we
look up yonder left oh wow we're gonna
scramble up there so this is excellent
for as a chemist for me to come here to
see where these elements first came from
it's really quite cool here we can see
evidence of the mining there this mine
closed many years ago but you can see
where the miners have drilled using hand
drills into these rocks to make holes to
put explosives in to break away the the
minerals so I'm very early on 17 late
1700s a naval officer called Arrhenius
visited the quarry and I think he may
have been prospecting for fuel and he
found the black rock which he thought
may have been coal when he picked the
rock up he found that it was far too
heavy to be coal coal is just simply
hydrocarbon Asia for carbonaceous
mineral but this rock was obviously too
heavy to be coal and he thought that
there must be something strange about it
he wondered whether it might be a new or
of tungsten which had recently been
found so he passed this material to a
colleague or a professor at the nearby
arbo University fur fur for analysis so
that's where the chemistry of the rare
earths is they recorded all the
lanthanide started with the discovery of
four new elements from that original
black mineral rock yes so we found the
quarry and it's it's breathtaking it's
um surprised that we were able to come
because everyone told us it was fenced
off and closed we didn't see any fences
anyway
somewhere here there's a sign which is
sort of commemorative of this site so
let's see if we can find this historic
landmark site
so we've now come up the side of the
quarry into the sunlight to find that
the original plaque from the American
Society of minerals is in situ so here
it says the ASM is designated yet to be
mine it to be mine sorry a historical
landmark for the discovery of four
periodic elements yttrium ytterbium
erbium and terbium and that's actually
in chronological order it reham was the
first one isolated from the black rock
and over a period of the next 40 to 50
years successive scientists we analyzed
that sample and were able to extract
both terbium and erbium initially
leading to the final isolation of
ytterbium in its purest form way back in
1950 so a period of a hundred years of
chemistry summed up in this sign from
this one specific quarry in in Sweden